hi what's up I'm Kim Petrus I'm here at
BuzzFeed and today I'm gonna tell you
about my first time sis first celebrity
you found out was a fan of yours
I was Paris Hilton and she wasn't my
first music video ever and I was a
nobody I had no songs out nothing nobody
knew my music nothing and she heard the
song and she was like I love the song
and I want to be in the video that was
incredible and I feel like nobody can
ever do anything bigger for me in my
whole entire life because that was the
start of everything and so meaningful
and I love Paris so much and that really
it was like made my life first time you
woo
odd wha the first time I would add was
randomly in the studio I was searching
for my producer tag I know it's just
like yelling things out and then it's
just like happening randomly one day
just like appeared I don't know why it
happened I don't know why it showed up I
just really been the silver lining in my
life like it's safe me I don't know it
was just random like four five years ago
wha first musical inspiration probably
like Ariel from like The Little Mermaid
or something she is a main pop girl
first cellphone you ever owned it was a
purple Nokia and it was incredible like
there was this like snake game on it
right but that but that was all I would
do all day and like download films yeah
flex with my ringtones and then like my
parents would get mad at me for like so
much money on ringtones I also
remembered like having the crazy frog
ringtone I want to collab with the crazy
frog I wonder how much of Calathes let's
let's link up in the studio first time
you messed up on stage oh my god I was
like five and my mom put on these leg
dance with my mom at like a small dance
studio in Germany I was wearing like a
Scottish outfit and I was like tap
dancing and the second like the lights
went on I started crying and needed to
get get get carried off the stage and I
was like so scared I was like this is my
moment was what I've been waiting for
I'm gonna get discovered and then I'm
just like pride and got carried Oh st.
so all my first times were usually like
mess ups that that should be like the
sum up of this video like oh my first
time so just terrible
like terrible experiences and then I got
better at them and then life you know
it's easier you stress less now I don't
cry on stage anymore it's lit first date
so the weird thing is like I never went
on like a real first date with anybody
ever like anybody I've ever dated was
like a friend of a friend or somebody
like from like school or somebody or
with me from work or things like that
like I've never actually gone on a date
with somebody you know just like an
official date
take me to Versace and then like Louie
and then to Chanel by music I don't have
a dream first date to be honest honestly
dates freaked me out really hard a lot
of people do love that kind of stuff
first song you wrote terrible my first
song I wrote was about this dude in like
second grade who didn't like me back
trash
so next first meme of yourself
you remember loving I think in general
just when people started saying the whoo
I bet that was hot or when people
started referencing the sensation so I
went to Australia and obviously I had to
let me to koala and hold one and the
koala I held like they switched it like
ripe I was like in line and there were
like all these like super like adorable
koalas and there was that one really
like scruffy looking like it was still
really cute and I held it and I took a
photo and I posted it and then there
were all these memes of it looking like
the old man who ate paint I'm like - a
lot of people I'm like only the girl who
held the Koala that looks like the men
who ate paint which is incredible feel
really honored a very iconic moment in
my life first album you bought um
spice world also a first movie that I
like dragged my parents to go with me
too because they would take me to like
Disney movies and all of that like every
movie I wanted to see but like spice
world I had to drag them into the
theatre so spice world first time you
performed on TV Germany it was in
Germany on like a breakfast show I was
like singing one of my old songs
everything was German it was like 4:00
a.m. that I had to get up I messed up
like a lot of it I've got like all the
choreo it was great but I'm like glad I
got that over with because now I'm just
like so amazing
like it doesn't even bother me that I
had this one like nervous moment because
now I'm just incredible with everything
I do immediately first thing you notice
in someone you're interested in
definitely humor is is a big thing so I
feel like I noticed that when people
just have like a product positive
attitude and just have fun because some
people have like a really nervous energy
and I'm like yeah it makes me nervous
like just when people have like a good
energy that's like the first thing I
think I noticed attitude and energy and
the color of your aura you know like I
notice it right away I'm like lavender
first big purchase my first MacBook Pro
I was really like saving up for that one
all the waitress in Germany and my
MacBook Pro was like my first thing that
I got for myself that I was really proud
of and really started my career and like
my life as a songwriter so yeah I still
have that first Black Book Pro enough to
love it first time you realized you were
famous I'm still waiting I can still
walk down the street nobody notices Who
I am you can still live a normal life
the hell I'm still waiting I kind of
feel like I don't ever want to feel
famous either like I just always want to
keep pushing you just like we see the
same person but yeah I've had I've had
I've had a bunch of pinch me moments
especially like recently selling out my
first for Demi Lovato coming to my show
meeting Marc Jacobs and like fashion
designers after shows yeah just like
meeting meeting people is always like
crazy like meeting people you've looked
up to for a long time I'm just always
amazing first kiss um it was in Germany
with my German boyfriend my first German
boyfriend it was really like not hot at
all I was just like super nervous
obviously I like wanted to kiss somebody
and like rehearsed it a million times
but it was just bad it wasn't good
become a little bit better at it is
anybody's first kiss good I don't think
so so if your first kiss sucked they're
gonna be alright you can still be a pop
star so this was my first time so I hope
you guys had fun make sure you listen to
my new record that's app now
and thanks for having me this is really
fun
[Music]